and welcome back to the realist podcast
in the dunya today we're here with the
home base masha'allah and we are on what
the third day of ramadan bro the days
are getting so plated with each other
already man how's the how's the fasting
going for you guys
you guys i'm tired already man
well i couldn't get much sleep last
night man
yeah angel's just telling me the same
thing actually
yeah yeah you know you know it's crazy i
actually only slept i think
three hours last night as well but i
don't feel it
yeah that's what i was going to say
yeah so much buttercup in this month
wrong yeah i mean yeah yeah
alhamdulillah
how about when i'm home how's the
fasting going
what's going on
they're telling us to get some sleep
do these videos come on now we could
sleep later we could sleep when we're in
gennady
they want the emergency right away
all right guys uh we know we know that
you guys are eager to hear what it is
have some stuff at house and patience
shall we we'll get to that we're gonna
tell you what the emergency meeting is
for we're gonna tell you what the
emergency is in a bit
insha'allah towards that in the stream
but we will get there
anthony
i want to ask you a question especially
on how being his second ramadan is it
just me or does this ramadan seem
easier in terms of fasting than last
ramadan
yeah
yeah for sure i will say though i'm
doing a different schedule than i did
the first ramadan hustle
uh well the first ramadan
um i would literally
[Music]
wake up for support
then we'll do fuzzy now we just
knock right out and i would wake up at
like maybe
10
or 11
and then i would wake up for the rest of
the day and then i would go to sleep at
like
when i say like 11
or 12.
but like now i'm like i'm literally
staying up
all
night long bro
and i go to sleep after fuji
and then i'll wake up for
uh
and at some points yeah like i'll take
naps
but for the most part like i'm
i'm up i'm getting
you've been fasting too right
at least sporadically before ramadan
sporadically yeah you gotta control the
sexual urges man there we go bro there
we go the thing with me is usually in
ramadan the first day i feel a little
bit of like a dehydration headache
maybe day two but that's even pushing it
usually by day two and three i'm like
good for the rest of the month you know
what i mean but for this year the first
day it felt like it was in winter bro
you know how in winter the days are
short well i know doesn't know because
he hasn't had ramadan in winter but
there's days in winter bro where like
it's like from seven a.m to 5 starts to
like
3 30 or 4 p.m bro
which is super short
yeah
yeah
that's not the emergency bro
why would that be an emergency man
it's fine a lot but uh
well we'll get that in a few years
inshallah that went to ramadan we'll get
in a few years insha'allah it's going to
be nice nice and short
inshallah
how can one control his sexual desires
during ramadan so our brother angel
literally has a course about that which
we dropped the video a few days ago but
what's some like free gem that you could
just drop right now bro if you have any
it's controlling sexually well on top of
the fact that you're in ramadan like
it's a lot easier to control your sexual
urges
but
i'd say
the most you can do right now is
don't forget to
have some form of like exercise
right because like
when you have sexual urges it's just
it's literally just energy like sexual
energy
is literally just energy
you can use it for anything else
um
so yeah just
get make sure you're walking or doing
some form of like exercise either before
iftar or like
after you start
um this should help and then during the
day man like if if you're over here
having urges like well
maybe that should let you know that
you're probably not utilizing your time
appropriately during the fast
but yeah i'm not going to assume that of
you you know
massive 15 hours in new york is not so
bad bro there's some places in the world
that are like 19 20 hours bro
which is rough that they're probably on
one meal a day at that point bro
yeah
i'll make easier for them bless them the
harder it is the more reward though
inshallah
i don't keep it pg-13
i did
that's that's how not keeping a pg-13
boys
accepted for me
i mean i mean
okay
i mean we won't know to we won't we
won't know till we get there man we'll
find out and hopefully we won't get
there
i mean but you know i mean let us know
how this man yeah guys like that
smashed that like button bro i was gonna
ask another that question bro we got 246
viewers right now on hell bro how many
likes should we have
600 bro why do we not have 600 likes
guys smash that like button
if you don't want to smash that like
button you don't have to just understand
it really does help the algorithm the
only thing that helps live streams get
more impressions on youtube homepages
likes so that's it
well
seeing that comment reminds me of the
the one thing was like the shake was
asked by he was acid i said you could
tell i'm exhausted bro
well he was asked by like an atheist
like yo how are you gonna feel
when you die and you realize like
it doesn't
none of it was real
he's like
man i'm gonna feel a lot better than you
when you when you die and you see that
it was real and you're going straight to
jahannam yeah yeah
no
it's ingrained in my dna bro i can't
stop
i wanna i wanna take a question here
insha'allah inshallah go for it uh why
do you get what's what's uh about the
dean in ramadan
unlocked away i literally just made a
video about this angel the video i was
telling you about before i this is the
one i posted so um
it's not it's not all the shayateen that
are locked away the stronger ones the
hadith says they're chained up and there
are specific hadith that mentions
specifically the stronger ones and uh
some scholars say which means that the
the weaker ones are still running around
and some scholars say that them being
chained up doesn't mean that they can't
do anything
but they're more limited in their action
you guys ever seen those like those
drawings or those clips of like
prisoners with like the like the giant
metal like ball looks like a cannonball
a chain to their leg
it doesn't stop them from moving it just
makes it really hard so imagine it like
that like they're they're still doing
what they're doing but they're limited
in their action so that's why we feel
that boost of a man
but it's not like evil ceases to exist
subhanallah and bro where can they find
the video that you made
on my tick tock tick-tock
there we go
season chicken right not really an
emergency if you're not going to tell us
right away listen you seasoned hand
what i had to say to our emergent
situation it is an emergency it's pretty
it's pretty much an emergency you guys
are going to know but
we'll drop it how about this you guys
don't want to wait till the end of the
stream we'll drop it in like 10 minutes
or so 10-15 minutes inshallah
you're trying to answer some questions
you know
let's go let's go what are some things i
could do to stop smoking hookah
are you like addicted to it
is that what he's saying
i don't think
if he's addicted to the nicotine you
gotta replace it
you gotta replace it with something
we broke the system bro that's that's
probably how
i'm not as like seasoned in math as some
other people so i actually don't know
how that works either
what are your goals for ramadan and then
my goal for ramadan i actually made a
video about this as well i'm going into
ramadan
but uh my goal is to read four pages
four to five pages of quran after every
salah because if you do that
then you will end up reading the entire
quran by the end of ramadan it's
basically 20 to 21 pages a day
sisters who can't fast a week
then just
take the average amount of days or know
how many days you're going to miss or
how many days you did miss and then take
the total number of pages in the quran
divide by the number of days you can
fast and you can read quran that's how
many pages a day you have to
um
read
[Music]
that's a proper goal
what about you
my goal is to
memorize
allah
let's repeat it over and over again
yeah five bravo here
bro my goal
is to make sure i pray qiyam
at least most nights if not all
consistently you know because being in
the ramadan it kind of gives you that
like you gotta wake up for super bro
people that don't even wake up for fuji
bro there's no excuse because you most
of the people that i know that can't
pray fajr they pray during ramadan
because they ought to wake up for sure
so adding into the mix very simple allah
has made it very easy bro
urges aren't you able to be with your
spouse at night yeah you're able to be
with your spouse at night and do
anything else permissible
some people don't have sexual partners
though
yeah
um
editor just zoom in on his face let me
just start that
all right boys we got five ish five six
minutes left before we drop it
shall i get the likes up
next question
how does wasa work in the first place
well i mean it's pretty straightforward
on what we're told in the quran is our
faith on
he comes and he whispers in your ear and
he gives you bad thoughts now it's not
something you can physically hear in
your ear like someone's whispering
uh like you guys know those really
annoying people that come real close and
they like have super hot breath or
whisper in the ear it's not like that
it's just it's just intrusive thoughts
that you get when you get intrusive
thoughts that's the lust to us from
i've had a lot of fun because of the
renovations i'm doing so ignore me if my
voice cracks but you seek refuge in
allah against the cursed shaythan
against the curse satan
and you basically go on with your life
it's just uh
the the things that pop up in your head
you just gotta be mindful gotta be
as uh
i guess aware of these things as
possible because if you're not mindful
then you'll you won't notice
when it is an intrusive thought when it
is something that's actually
leading you
somewhere that ain't too good i will be
honest with you
you know
oh no is this true or false
reverts for suda
what
river's favorite surah surah al-rahman
i don't know bro can't speak on every
reverb
all i know is that is my favorite
oh no such a what does that even mean
chillo
how to deal with grief that's a good
question question a very good question
do any of you guys have experience with
losing a loved one or any type of greed
i just gotta go through it
you know before romney goes you
you go through it and it happens like
healing from it occurs and waves
so you don't heal like right away it's
not like oh you cry and then boom like
you're done like you're not even gonna
think about it you're never going to
feel it again
it's more like
it's really strong
and then it like eases up and then it
comes back and then ease up every time
it comes back it'll be like less and
less and less
until you get to the point where
it's not really
does it affect you the same way
but do you have something different
around me
no no i think essentially that that is
the the main thing because it's not
it's never linear you're going to have
good and bad days and it's going to take
time but overall what you need is that
time but it's what i was going to answer
is more so the perspective to have in
that time because it's getting through
that time that's that's that's difficult
allah
don't become super sad and do not grieve
indeed basically allah says indeed the
the believers will be successful at the
end
i believe that's what it says
i believe that's what it says
that you'll you'll be prosperous and
you'll have victory in the end as long
as you're a movement a believer
so allah and this was revealed after the
battle of lord when many many many
muslims died this was a really
depressing time for a lot of people
during this battle the people thought
that the prophet islam actually passed
away
so this was you know basically
encouragement from allah
and don't become sad don't become
depressed indeed you're going to have
victory in the end
and the prophet saw to islam
he said
that the strong believer is better and
more beloved to allah than the weak
believer and he gives you a formula of
how to go
basically from being weak in a state a
state of weakness to a state of strength
and i talked about that in a few videos
the hadith is online if you want to look
it up the full hadith is beautiful allah
but to get through that kind of grief
you have to put it through the lens of
islam which is what are you grieving
about
you grieve when you lose something
something that has happened something
that has passed i you know a loved one
passed away or left you or something you
lost something that ended up hurting you
and now you feel this grief because of
that loss when you understand that this
life is temporary including your time
here you understand that the whole point
of it is to go to jannah and in jannah
you won't feel any kind of
hardship or discontentment or sadness
and when you understand that
wholeheartedly it's not going to
completely like
make you not care about anything in this
world but it will make it a lot easier
let's say you lose a loved one
insha'allah who is the muslim then you
can always have the
you know contentment knowing that insha
allah one day you'll see them again in
jannah and then you have to focus on
getting there
[Music]
guys
literally a couple more questions and
then we're going to quickly drop the the
news but yeah that's solid bro do you
have anything ahead on her i don't
really have too much experience with
grief no i was on i already had in my
bit i was actually like
brainstorming some like beautiful idea
for the three of us which i'll we'll
talk about that at the end of the stream
or after the stream you know unless you
guys want to talk about it i think i
think this person's a hindu just based
on the name because they commented why
is there so much hate against pagans in
your book and they also wrote
then why so much attacks on hindu idols
so
you guys have anything to say about that
um i mean hate is a strong word to
let's say you have something that's
wrong
all right anything that is wrong that
you preach against because it's
incorrect it's wrong like let's say you
know people in india persecuting muslims
we we call out against that very
strongly because it's incorrect the
worst thing anyone can do is associate
partners with god it's a detestable
thing to do so the reason we go at
pagans is because not only are they
associating partners with god but it's
with all due respect the saddest form of
association of partners with god because
it's literally something you created
literally like a statue that you made
or that you worship or a concept that
you made into a statue that you ended up
worshiping
yeah and i actually have a friend who is
hindu and he told me that like
the people who are
like true hindus like the real real
practitioners of hinduism
they will tell you that there is only
one
god and if you actually look
into the
ancient vedas
the scriptures
um it actually spoke about there being
one god so it's like i said in a long
a long time ago where
allah has been trying to give the
message for a long time it's been like a
the telephone game
and um every time the message was
altered it just
moved on to the next person the next
group of people that's why you have a
lot of religions and spiritual practices
that have
pieces of the puzzle they have like
similarities
and then some have more than others
and the reason some have more than
others is because they received more of
the message before they altered it in
islam
it was never altered so the full message
was received
um that's why
if you actually get to like the base
base
basis of
hinduism
before you start having all these idols
and before you have like all this other
stuff getting in there
it was actually very aligned with islam
so you can clearly see when it began to
become
altered and this is why
god says in the book you know like do
not worship idols because this is
clearly
not the way
yeah 100 and i just want to comment
specifically on this this comment here
um it's not a problem for us if it was a
problem for muslims then we would have
been commanded to wipe idolatry from the
face of the earth but it was only wiped
in mecca and madina so if you want and
actually when the muslims took over
kharasana they allowed the people to
continue to worship their idols they
didn't stop them and then eventually the
people just accepted this time because
they realized it was the truth so it
doesn't hurt us like to be honest we we
don't care in a way that it affects us
we care in the way that we know it'll
affect you and does it hurt someone it's
gonna hurt a lot when people go to hell
for it to be completely honest it will
hurt a lot so we want to you know save
people from that and deliver the message
of truth
why does that hurt you
and i mean bro just think about it
like it doesn't make sense
to worship
uh
like okay let's take
your name is uh shiva shivaji
so let's say shiva for example i'm not
even gonna
say anything bad about you but let's
let's take shiva for example
was shiva an actual person
if the if if that's true
then that completely eliminates
the uh
it completely eliminates divinity from
the picture you can't be divine if you
were created
jonathan is divine is the creator
so that's number one
and then number two like
if it wasn't a person if she was never
actual person it was just
made by
people like a concept well then again
like it's it's not real it's it's just
it's just this uh this concept this idea
so
again i'm not talking bad i'm just
saying like two different scenarios
if he was real if he wasn't real neither
is going to benefit you
you know so
i hope that clears if there's any
confusion for you though
someone wrote insecurities out loud
subhanallah it's not you see a lot of
the time they are insecurities but
sometimes people just need a little bit
of clarification
all right we're going to take three more
questions and then we're going to
quickly drop it
and go for the answers
uh let's see
okay i think this is perfect for you how
can i stop watching prawn
uh it's
it takes a lot
it takes a lot but
i'd say like one little key thing that
you can take away like right now
is that
you really need to understand why you
want to quit
right like you you can't just say that
you want to quit because
we could say a lot of things like but
you don't
you don't actually stick to something
until there's like a clear-cut reason
why you're doing what you're doing right
like
maybe
you know you want to make money
to
i don't know
maybe travel
um
maybe not have any bills help your
family out get more stuff like that
whatever the case may be right
but you just you don't really feel
compelled to do it
but the moment that you have
a clear-cut reason
where it's like yo i have to do it now
then it makes it that much more easier
to actually
quit watching
bro
okay next question khalid writes do you
have any plan to create a charity in
ramadan or after ramadan so subhanallah
just from
off the rip we don't
alhamdulillah insha allah next year we
do but the main goal that we have right
now is we're going to take a percentage
of our proceeds that you know we we make
from all the supporters for the channel
insha allah and at the end of this year
or just anytime this year we have a goal
and we've said it before we want to
build a masjid insha allah and anyone
that contributes you're going to get a
piece of the word definitely best
believe that
but the thing is
you know alhamdulillah we're getting to
a point where the deadline to reach that
right the milestone is going to be
sooner than later alhamdulillah our goal
was at the end of our first or second
year but alhamdulillah might even be
much sooner than that and we might run a
fundraiser you know because if y'all
want like a gofundme or something like
that and we can raise more money build
more masjids then why not
also the brother said he was deaf so i
just want to give him a little
yes
in sign language
how can i maximize my experience in
ramadan
yo
take the time to reflect
you know like
don't just try to stay busy so you don't
feel the fast like
just take time to just chill out
conflict
on your life on
on the creator on the religion on your
spiritual practice on your family
everything just take that time out
you know like the other day
um i was busy i was working but then it
was raining and i was like
i'm just going to take this time to
chill out so i went out to the porch
and i was just reading the quran in the
rain it was the most beautiful thing man
just being in nature
alone with with all the like
the ambient noise and then just reading
the quran and like them reflecting on it
all just looking at everything
like that's that's like
i don't know to me that that's that's
how you get
the most out of fasting
you know i sent you guys a message on uh
our group chat whenever you got time
but insha allah i think it's time that
we drop the news
and i think it's only appropriate that
we do it sooner than later and then we
gotta end the stream insha allah
so
let me just quickly had this yeah a
quick super chat from brother yahya
what resources would you recommend to
muslims living in the western society to
further their knowledge in the dean
harambe bro go in
so first and foremost every single time
i ask this question i recommend the i3
institute the letter i the number three
institute.ca the yd program the young
daiyi program it'll teach you basically
all all the basics um but
by the way it's free two hours a week
actually include that different times um
different languages as well
uh so it's it's amazing there if you
want something in person
then fine go to your local measured see
what classes they have in person they
usually have a teacher who teaches based
on a book maybe of you know al-qaeda or
or something uh from like imam and
allah or from imam shafi or imam abu
hanifa and they'll go and teach you in
death but the most important thing when
seeking knowledge is that you learn it
from a teacher who's you know qualified
to teach who's righteous inshallah
that's the most important thing
and we got a live testimony right here
from uh brother anthony romney's a good
teacher by the way marshall
man bless you bro you're a good student
masha allah
yo didn't did sam have a super chat
no something
so i'm just clowning bro sam's usually
uh
the chat clown bro keeping us
entertained
anyway the news that we are going to
drop guys smash that like button first
if you guys want the news not just plain
um
it's it's it's kind of a little bit of a
transformative change insha'allah to the
channel but
we are going to be shifting gears in the
type of content that we put out
alhamdulillah
so
god willing right the goal of our
channel right now is to grow as much as
possible
and we are trying to completely blow up
the analytics we have some goals that we
want to hit in terms of subscriber count
inshaallah and even exceed that if allah
wills
and what we're going to be doing now
is we're going to be switching to daily
uploads so instead of the normal
two you know
live streams or podcasts that you guys
get per week right and you guys get some
guests every now and then too we're
still going to be doing podcasts and
live streams the frequency is going to
be lesson though to maybe like one to
like three times a month but you guys
are still gonna get daily content and
they're gonna be a little bit shorter in
terms of the duration right so maybe
like six seven eight minutes um but
they're gonna be very good and they're
gonna be edited right so we're looking
for a proper editor
this is also kind of
the the new i guess the emergency in a
way it is emergent because if there's a
time pressure you know
we got 48 hours
for someone that we're going to hire in
sha allah
maybe max 72 but ideally 48 hours
once this video is done you guys can
head over to the description box and
there's going to be a google drive file
as soon as you click on that file
there's going to be like a five or six
minute video it's going to be a raw
video it's going to be just a clip from
a podcast that we did it's nothing
special but what we want you all to do
is take that video clip take that raw
use imovie final cut pro whatever you
guys use to edit for all the editors and
just edit the crop out of that make it
as as nice as you can
if you want i did give my instagram in
the in the description box dm me if you
want like a little bit more specific you
know advice and feedback into what we're
looking for exactly
but we're looking for just high
retention dopamine you know just to keep
people on the screen and whatever type
of edit is the best one if you guys
don't want the position you will get the
position if you don't want it we'll go
reach out to the next person in line
however in 48 hours this is the deadline
we are definitely looking for an editor
this will be a paid position and
inshallah it's supposed to be long term
we're not looking for just quick you
know a couple days couple months we're
looking for like long term if you do
good work inshallah we'll compensate you
and we're really trying to reinvest back
into the channel and grow the channel if
i missed anything guys
let me let me add it in so we're looking
for a video editor
and inshallah we're looking for a
thumbnail
editor
someone who can create
legitimate thumbnails that you know
attract
you hit everything perfectly bro
alhamdulillah that's it
i don't mean anything else you want to
add
nah if you guys aren't editors and you
know someone who is then forward this to
them and say hey i know a great channel
best channel in the world and they're
looking for video editors
the best video editors in the world and
uh yeah hit him up inshallah
someone will bro i don't want to pay
anything
who's that they gotta pay anything no
one's gotta pay no okay you know he's
not paying anything you're not paying
anything you will be paid if you are the
one that uh that takes up
maybe they they meant that they don't
want to be paid if they work for us but
even then at the end of the day like
we're just the type of folk that we like
to give back where we get good and if
you are doing good work we're not we're
not people that are going to be like oh
you know even if you want to be like oh
just accept it as celica we're still
going to compensate you financially
um and you know may allah accept it for
me anyway
really quickly i just want to put this
up here
uh because she did send a super chat
earlier go for it there you go
this was her amazing super chat of two
bucks
bro subhanallah i remember seeing that
and i was like that's not really a
question but
it depends on perspective you know if
you look at it somewhere it might be a
question yeah [ __ ] about it
spaghetti and meatballs
it depends what kind of sauce you're
using yeah
how much y'all gonna pay i guess you
gotta
get the best uh edit to find out because
you won't even be considered without a
proper edit inshallah but
expect that it will go up a lot over
time as the barakah keeps going up as a
support and you know everything keeps
going up inshallah
okay
if there's anything else from y'all then
uh we should wrap it up just a summary
quick uh tldr make sure that
48 hours so ideally by wednesday april
6th
at 12 p.m eastern standard time
so this is noon you know what we'll make
it wednesday night just because people
might be fasting all day
so wednesday at
8 00 p.m eastern standard time is the
deadline wednesday april 6th at 8pm
eastern standard time
reach out to me on instagram if i had
fit
um just because i'm going to be super
active on wednesday for this and in the
meantime if you guys want specific
advice on how to edit what we're looking
for once again even though we kind of
mentioned more that's what was a little
bit while ago
ask me in the dm um but wednesday what
we're gonna do
is we're gonna open like this either
it's gonna be like through my dm you can
hit me up give me the link for google
drive i'm going to share with the boys
and we're going to quickly review them
in sha allah we'll have a decision by
the end of the week
and we will speak further on it but stay
tuned for friday right even though i did
say we're going to take a little bit
step back from the podcast
we are going to have you know our second
weekly live stream this friday
12 p.m eastern standard time
5 p.m uk time very special episode we
have a revert to islam a sister
from judaism
and we are going to be interviewing her
inshallah so stay tuned for that
all right
don't you guys already use an editor
kind of it's
but we haven't been serious with it like
now we're really cracking down and um
we're going to talk about this idea that
just came to my mind
a few minutes ago and if if it's popping
if we're going to get it then
oh y'all in for something real nice
that's all i got to say
all right
okay next oh so you're not gonna say no
you're gonna just tell us after the call
do you want me to say no
i mean it's it's something that we kind
of talked about but like we didn't
expect to do it for a while but i'm
thinking that like you know what the
time is now say it as it is bro but we
gotta end the stream like one or two
minutes
no i'll tell you guys i'll tell you guys
i'm sure okay cool uh a bond writes what
about the thumbnail
i don't know any advice for that
uh
just high click-through rate something
that's very catchy and we'll get yeah
yeah so with the clip
you figure it out right with the clip
that you you're gonna edit or you just
look through the clip
and then see
what either what would be best to make
as a thumbnail or what you could take
from the clip and then add to it to make
the thumbnail but it has to be
has to be something that like really
pulls it can't just be
um basically like the thumbnails we've
been doing like yeah the thumbnails
we've been doing they've been good
alhamdulillah but we can do better so
that's what we're looking for
and just to clarify they're not going to
be the same person necessarily so
they're two different people one is
we're looking for a video editor and one
we're looking for a thumbnail designer
um also when is your merch out sister
sally asks merch was supposed to come
out at 50k subs in sha allah which will
be very soon but the way that we have
our goals right now
inshallah 100k subs is going to be very
soon as well god willing so
ideally look out for it around 100k it's
gonna be sooner than you guys think if
the video editor goes to work yeah sam's
a troll
sounds a troll bro big troll
but anyway with that being said
i think uh
i want to tell you all that may allah
accept all of our fasts keep us on the
on the straight path
um make it easy for us in this time of
physical stress you know ramadan is not
really psychologically stressing i think
at least to me it's very physically
stressing to a lot of people so may
allah just keep us you know grounded
keep us with high iman high taqwa
and uh make it a breeze inshallah so
that when ramadan is done
we don't lose the new habits that we
built and cultivated this month that
they transcend and carry on going
forward i mean
i mean
i mean
we do have one last super chat
from brother khalid may allah bless you
may he keep you strong in your faith and
may he help all of us die in a state of
uh muslim or a state of islam a state
pleasing to allah allah i mean
like that being said
this y'all our live emergency
bye
with that being said
[Music]
foreign